These are significantly sized holes.
They are.
It was so loud.
This happened
when my husband and I were asleep and
my grandkids
could have been spending the night.
It was about a dozen bullets
fired into Debbie O'Malley's home.
She was one of four Democratic officials
targeted in a series of drive
by shootings
weeks after the 2022 midterms.
The Chicago Police shooting,
a newly
unsealed indictment
now reveals federal charges
against this man, Solomon Pena,
for being the mastermind
of the shootings.
He's a former Republican candidate
on the 2022 ballot.
Pena lost by a landslide but tweeted
he stood with Trump
and never conceded his own race
in New Mexico. Hi, my name's Solomon.
Can I speak with Debbie O'Malley?
Ring video
from shortly after the election
captures him
going to one of the Democrats homes.
Prosecutors
say he blamed them for his election loss.
And according to the indictment, Pena
then texted those home addresses
to accomplices
to carry out the shootings, writing
They just certified it.
They were literally laughing at us.
Prosecutors say Pena directly
took part in two of the shootings.
None of the victims were injured.
We've got the rest over here.
Bernalillo County Commissioner
Adrian Balboa was also targeted.
Eight bullets were fired at her house,
four of them into the room
where she had
just been playing with her granddaughter.
It makes me angry
that one person makes it angry
that we have a former president
and current elected officials
in the highest level of government
that think it's okay to,
you know, invoke violence
in these situations.
As the country kicks off
another election cycle,
federal prosecutors
say the message from New Mexico is this.
We all stand here together, united
to say that acts of violence
will never stop an
American from doing her duty.
There are 11 federal
counts in this indictment.
They vary from conspiracy
charges, election interference
to firearms violations.
If convicted, Pena does face
a mandatory minimum of 60 years
behind bars.
And, Jake,
we did reach out to his attorney.
We did not hear back.